so you have a pitch meeting for me yes
we do the batman i have been anxiously
awaiting this if you guys don't know
pitch meetings has officially moved from
screenrat to starting its own channel so
there's a link in the description box
for the original the batman pitch
meeting make sure to subscribe to their
channel because yeah this is one of the
best segments on youtube leave a like if
you can let's get to it to love the hell
out of this movie i'm excited
[Music]
so you have a new batman movie for me
yes sir i do and i'm thinking we make
this the darkest gotham yet oh yeah oh
yeah we're gonna make it seem like this
city passed some kind of weird one light
bulb per household sounds very dark you
know it sir because we got to make these
movies darker and darker and darker and
darker that's just good business how do
you figure well sir we keep going like
this pretty soon people will pay to see
a completely dark screen and we could
play some kind of batman audio book or
something that will save us a ton of
money yeah yeah
batman oh i was thinking we get robert
pattinson oh i see what you're doing
twilight vampire vampire bat bat man
very clever actually no it's just
because he turned into a real good and
accomplished actor since the twilight
movies good time i'm enjoying myself
sure that's never mind you know really
quick i just wanted to say that it's
really interesting that robert pattinson
went through it because when he was
first cast a lot of people went oh the
twilight guy but it was such a quick
turnaround of actually robert
pattinson's a really good actor right
now the weird hurdle he had to overcome
was the fact that there were people who
really wanted you know ben affleck to
still continue on the dc eu so that's
really where the fight started happening
so rather than him being backlash for
his casting he was backlash because of
all the batmans that are going on so
anyway as batman he's gonna be dark and
brooding right okay but then as bruce
wayne he's gonna be brooding and dark
you need that dichotomy yeah yeah he's
gonna have dark eyeliner and hair in
front of his face and say stuff like
you're not my dad like it's 2006 or
something right and this guy's batman
suit is totally bulletproof i mean bad
guys just unload machine guns onto his
chest and he's not affected in the lease
wow so i guess his mouth must be covered
too right otherwise they could just aim
at that no that's completely exposed but
nobody's noticed that why not because
that works so who's he going up against
in this movie
the main one of which is the riddler oh
that guy riddles sir does sir so he's
going around killing corrupt people in
power and leaving little riddles for
batman oh i bet he is so then throughout
the movie batman's gonna look at these
riddles and then solve them pretty much
immediately nice but sometimes he
doesn't solve them immediately and that
means he's got to go stand on a rooftop
with gordon or catwoman for an extended
period of time that makes sense who's
going to start digging around gotham's
criminal underground right getting to
know the sketchy figures and stuff what
are we talking about here there's
freaking carmine falcone and then
there's the penguin who's falcone's
right-hand penguin oh we got penguin in
the movie what's he gonna do he's gonna
be like hey oh what are you doing a very
italian-american flightless bird that's
right sir so obviously i was thinking
we'd get colin farrell to play him what
yeah just cover the guy in so much
makeup and prosthetics that even after
people google it they're still like
really i mean i guess we could do that
sure and so eventually riddler's gonna
attach a bomb around the neck of this
corrupt d.a and send him to a funeral of
the mayor who he also killed oh yeah and
this bomb ends up exploding right in
batman's face he didn't know it was
gonna blow up no he did there was a
clear timer on it so so he didn't take
cover not even a little so he goes
flying backwards well i guess that's
going to hurt the exposed bottom of his
face not even a little but he is knocked
unconscious oh that's got to be a pretty
severe concussion nope so then the
police bring him to the police building
you know i gotta say like he's pointing
out all the things that every time i
watched it i'm like you should have some
injury especially in your most grounded
realistic take on batman that one
shirtless shot behind his back with some
scarring and does not suffice how to say
holy scar under the armor
yeah like your face should be banged up
you should have a concussion you're not
super human you know and even after that
he might go into it he does like on the
bat wing
oh dude he should have had his head
ripped off from that he should have had
so many broken limbs i'm bruce wayne
so then the police bring him to the
police building you know where you bring
injured people so they unmask him they
don't know so then he manages to escape
by gliding off the top of their building
and smacking into a little bridge thing
i mean that's got to be a pretty severe
concussion too no no no okay so then
eventually batman thinks that penguin is
this informant that he's looking for
right so he chases him down and a bunch
of cars and trucks explode it's going to
look very cool oh wow geez yeah it's
going to be crazy intense but then turns
out it wasn't him you know that wasn't
the informant so all those people in the
exploded cars died so batman can follow
an incorrect hunch that's right at
whoops whoops
batman is going to have this
conversation with he'll be correct down
did you know your dad paid me to kill a
journalist back in the day did you know
that oh man that's gonna shatter
batman's world it does so then batman
goes to confront alfred about this and
alfred's like oh yeah no that's not true
oh yeah it turns out the crime guy was
lying that checks out yeah glad that was
resolved resolved immediately yeah so
what else happens well eventually
he's gonna figure out that falcone you
know the bad guy yeah he's gonna figure
out that he's the bad guy right i gotta
say i i don't know about you but i feel
like falcone being the rat was like such
a long movie but i feel like so early on
it's probably falcone right he's the
least likely person at this point
because you think like oh he's the head
he wouldn't be the rat he's he's got to
be this guy because in the mid when you
put on your mystery movie hat you're
like who's the least likely guy he's the
most like yeah for me and like almost
everyone i talked to they're like yeah i
figured out pretty early on that it was
falcon who was the rat hell line's up
two hours later
so he brings him out of this gangster
club called the iceberg lounge and when
he's under this streetlight riddler
snipes them
and turns out that's exactly what ridler
wanted batman to do because earlier
there was a clue about bringing someone
out into the light that was referencing
this exact street light it was
very vague
later riddler's like there was no way
for me to kill that guy otherwise you
know he's never out in the open oh okay
except for the very public funeral there
about that earlier in the movie what and
so yeah then riddler's in jail and
falcone is dead okay wow sounds like a
great movie oh we're not done sir no
we're not done no no it's gonna feel
like maybe we should be but we're gonna
keep going you see riddler actually kind
of thought he and batman were working
together okay and there's this whole
other layer to riddler's plan like he
has a group of followers online that
he's been scheming with what's the plan
flood the city and shoot a bunch of
people oh my god that escalated so much
from killing gangsters and crooked
politicians it did yeah cause we gotta
end these on big set pieces i guess we
do yeah so how does batman figure this
out we'll see batman figures out that
one of riddler's murder weapons is this
tool you use to tuck in carpets how does
he figure that out well he happens to
run into a cop who happens to start
talking about how he happens to have an
uncle who works in the carpet business
oh very specific uncles are tight they
sure are sir so now batman looks under
this carpet and finds the specifics of
ridler's plan oh boy so now batman's
gotta rush to this arena and fight some
twitch commenters it's pretty serious
they're in riddler cosplay and stuff it
doesn't sound too serious but it's gonna
be and batman's gonna get a shotgun
blast to the chest but he's got his
completely bulletproof suit right so it
doesn't hurt him yeah this time it does
so he's like ow ow ooh stop
but there's still a bunch of cosplayers
around wow okay so i guess it's gonna be
pretty tough to get out of that
situation huh actually it's gonna be
super easy barely an inconvenience oh
really yeah because see batman's got
some green juice like a smoothie no it's
like an injection and it gives him a
real weakness what was that unclear oh
okay well good that he had it hey man
adrenaline action movie tropes things
you inject yourself with are awesome i
have never looked at it in just that
lens of oh they're just like people you
hate online who is fighting yeah oh yeah
yeah literally they're [ __ ] posters man
that's so funny because that's what they
are they're just cueing on [ __ ] posters
out here trying to feel important
they're commentators who really got
involved you know a lot of times you
find these people online who are so
vitriolic you're like yeah they just say
that behind the keyboard and this is the
version of those ones who actually
decided to take a stand that's deep
indeed this movie works on so many
layers so then he's beating up one of
the cosplayers and the cosplayer is like
my name is vengeance which is what
batman calls himself oh freaking
nickname steeler because the batman kind
of stopped and he's like whoa i guess i
sure learned a lesson here today yeah
sure sounds that way but then there's
this big electrical wire flailing around
and people are going to get electrocuted
because there's water everywhere oh no
yeah so batman selflessly cuts the wire
and gets electrocuted and falls from
super high up oh my god is he okay yep
oh yeah he's fine so yep okay so good
totally okay so then he takes a flare
and he guides a bunch of people out of
this flooded area into i guess another
flooded area because you know
everything's flooded a very underwater
gotham yeah or something of have to we
kind of have to and then batman and
catwoman kind of ride their motorcycles
next to each other and kind of split off
like it's the end of a fast and furious
movie oh it sounds like a great movie
wait is it done now yeah three hours
later it is yeah great well it'll be
nice to have a good cinematic experience
you know it seems like everything is
just streaming shows these days that's
so true sir it will be nice
and then you know what we can do if it's
a success what's that
[Music]
[Laughter]
yep i mean to me it sounds like wb was
so confident in this movie because they
were announcing these spin-offs before
this movie even came out so you know
that was another good indicator of the
quality of the cinematic experience
all right guys well make sure to
subscribe to the proper pitch meeting
channel from here on out you subscribe
to us check out all the batman [ __ ] we
talked about over the past week had a
four hour long spoiler talk my goodness
leave a like and hey let's do a peep
michael linden michael you know where
i'm going with this if anybody could
turn into the riddler here at the
patreon i think it would be you cuz you
got that look about you you look like a
sophisticated guy you look like an
intelligent guy a guy who could probably
orchestrate a very interwoven
interlocking rube goldberg machine of a
plan so intense in fact that we wouldn't
even figure it out we would be totally
useless in the wake of your grand master
plan mchale so hey we love you here we
don't want you to go off the deep end
start rallying all your supporters
because i know that those are just going
to be the other people at our patreon
turn them against us what do we have
then mikhail just darkness upon darkness
and you are a beacon of light my friends
so be well and uh hope you're having a
nice march it's almost spring time get
out there and enjoy the day mikhail
we'll see you soon see you soon
[Music]